despite originally refusing to remove
controversial footage included in its
horror hit bird box Netflix has now
changed its mind the film stars Sandra
Bullock as a single mother living in a
post-apocalyptic world where monsters
convince humans to commit suicide if
they catch sight of them the Canadian
Press confirms that the streamer will
remove from Bird box footage of the
real-life Loch Megantic rail disaster
that took place in 2013 an unnamed
spokesperson for the streaming giant
released an email statement to the
outlet that reads Netflix on the
filmmakers of bird BOTS have decided to
replace the clip we're sorry for any
pain causes a lark Megantic community
for those unaware the initial curse of
bird box includes footage from a train
crash that happened on July 6 2013 in
LAC Megantic Quebec Canada that day a
freight train loaded with crude oil
derailed from the tracks and crushed
several of the trains cars exploded and
then caught fire the accident left 47
people dead a large portion of Loch
Megantic downtown buildings completely
destroyed and most of the city's
downtown area ruined and in need of
rebuilding clips of the train tragedy
appeared within the first few minutes of
Byrd box drawing the scene in which
Malory and her sister Jessica are
watching the news on television they see
massive explosions and total devastation
racking a town footage meant in the film
to indicate that the world is
experiencing a mass epidemic of
unexplained violence people exhibiting
psychotic behavior
Netflix reportedly obtained the clips
from stock footage company pond5 where
individuals can purchase images and
clips including those from newscasts
that depict sensitive events another of
the streamers projects a sci-fi
television show travelers also
implemented lac-megantic disaster
footage which travellers production
company Peacock Alley Entertainment
stated wasn't intended to dishonor the
tragic events of 2013 a spokesperson
from pond5 also issued an apology for
the use of the footage in travellers we
deeply regret that this happened and
sincerely apologized to anyone who was
offended
especially the victims and their
families we are contacting all customers
who have purchased any related clips to
ensure they are aware of the sensitive
nature of this footage additionally
we're proactively reordering content of
this nature while continuing to improve
our guidance for usage when Netflix was
made aware of the situation as it
relates to Byrd box however the streamer
refused to
remove the footage at first a
spokesperson indicated that Netflix
would keep the clip in the movie and
would be quote looking at ways to do
things differently moving forward
many were outraged at Netflix's original
decision none more than lark Megantic
Mayor Julie Morin and Kubek culture
minister Natalie wah Morin wrote that
the use of the footage and subsequent
refusal to take it out of Bird box after
knowing all the facts showed a complete
lack of respect for the people of Locke
Megantic and those affected by the 2013
disaster she said it's hard enough for
our citizens to see these images when
they are used normally and respectfully
on the news
just imagine to have them used as
fiction as if they were invented while
singled out Netflix CEO Reed Hastings
for criticism writing that Netflix was
exhibiting a quote lack of compassion
empathy and solidarity in its decision
she also stated that the Kubik
government's found it unbelievable that
Netflix wouldn't remove the clips from
Byrd box or think that it was okay to
implement them in the first place
I think it's a huge mistake now that
Netflix has reversed its choice having
already updated the film as of the
making of this video
Morin is satisfied and willing to look
past the streamers initial refusal
she said yes there was a delay but I
think in the end was more important for
me is that we have a solution to this
situation we felt was important to
settle morin further noted that the
entertainment industry needs to reflect
on this and other situations like this
to hopefully create a new standard for
the use of stock footage in films and
television series check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
loop of videos but your favorite films
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]